in Indonesia Khoirul extremely high
speed up heading towards the location of
the world churches
I am yeaaaah right now the diverse and
remote cooperated with our office word
blackbox in map location for yesterday
Woi Dino the Navy ship seconds now
from the bikin transmitted from books
flight data recorder and northwest
corner and It also that location The
world that that dabking signal is from
the crush location Under the bridge
Bridge Tibet some of the part of the
facial and Some Other personal
belongings so the passengers and looking
at the date that most of  the bridges in
the very-very small parts and the day it
looks like that they Ever E
broken the very high impact rabbit-
worth  is recording the
communication between the two files sign
in the copied and then we now that until
now There is no ame shorof like distress
signal from  in er Traffic Controller
show it looks like that the east tedak
siten happened in every student and now
You're So get out from the device the reader
the outside the communication PT IPTN
nothing now that the indirect learning
and they begin to interview every
person involved  the accident including
the controller and a
Cek NISN Mechanical and Brother Datsel We
hope that from the copied flight
recorder Enno Angle data recorder that
weekend review a lot about what happened
is it at mechanical engine or something
else naas khai
Hai try you Wa